here's one how-to bit of advice we hope
you'll never ever need how to free
yourself if you're bitten by an anaconda
these scientists are trying to capture
an anaconda in Venezuela so they can
study
unfortunately the Anaconda a snake so
big that the larger ones can swallow a
human being in one gulp sees this as an
invasion of its space very bad for one
particular scientist the anaconda has
sunk its fangs into the scientists hand
okay now here's the advice part of this
video if this happens to you do not
repeat do not yank your hand away push
your finger forward okay the teeth of an
anaconda curved backwards to hold its
prey once it bites into it that's why
the scientist has to force his hand
deeper into the mouth of the anaconda to
free his skewered finger
backing of it
the bite of an anaconda is not venomous
this snake is a member of the boa
constrictor family and kills its victims
by squeezing them to death still getting
your finger impaled on one of its fangs
is not recommended in fact we recommend
you leave the handling of anacondas to
professionals like this because well
even they're not good enough to keep
from occasionally getting used as a chew
toy
good thing this wasn't one of the
28-foot 500-pound behemoths that are out
there